Speaker 1: In the midst of everything happening
with the Supreme Court. We learned last week
through this leaked decision that in all
likelihood, unless something changes,
the current Supreme Court is going to be voting
to overturn Roe v Wade as soon as the end of June.
In the midst of all of this protests at the
houses of Supreme Court justices, etc., etc.,
and of course, the search for the leaker, which I
really wonder how that's going. Public confidence
in the Supreme Court has absolutely collapsed from
where it was. There is a new poll. Confidence in
Supreme Court collapsed since conservatives took
control. This is a new Yahoo! News YouGov poll
which shows that over the last 20 months, American
confidence in the court has collapsed. This is a
period that started with Trump and Republicans
putting in that six three conservative majority
with the replacement of Ruth Bader Ginsburg by Amy
Coney Barrett. And that this has culminated with
the leak of the draft signaling that Roe v Wade
will be overturned. The last time Yahoo! YouGov
asked about confidence in the court with September
of 2020. That was just a few days after Ruth Bader
Ginsburg died. Then 70% of registered voters said
they had some or a lot of confidence in the court,
whereas 30% said they had a little or none. In the
new survey, a 40 point swing where now only half
of voters expect some or a lot of confidence,
while the other half now expresses a little
or no support. That is those are incredible
numbers. And as the article points out,
views on key aspects of American life
rarely shift that suddenly. And the question
is why? The question is why now? There's tons
of speculation as to why. But one important
element of this to understand is that we now
have five of the nine justices on the court
appointed by presidents who lost the popular
vote. So just take a step back for a second.
Most Americans believe that abortion
should be legal in most cases.
Americans are more in favor of abortion today
than at any point during the Roe v Wade era.
And we have this forthcoming decision where
the Supreme Court is going to say, now we're
getting rid of Roe v Wade. Abortion isn't even
going to be a right anymore. Okay. Well, let's
look at the makeup. It's a63 conservative court
in which five of the nine justices were chosen
by presidents who lost the popular vote. George
W Bush selected Chief Justice Roberts and Samuel
Alito. A Donald Trump selected Neil Gorsuch, Brett
Kavanaugh and Amy Coney Barrett. Five of the nine.
The loser of the popular vote. Got
to pick. Okay. That's number one.
Number two, those choices, again, made by a
president who lost the popular vote were confirmed
by a completely anti-democratic Senate in which
California with 30 something million people
and Wyoming with under a million people. I hope
I'm getting these population numbers correct. 30
something million, one under 1 million. California
and Wyoming have the same number of votes.
Consider the lopsided and undemocratic nature
of this. And of course, we have to also say one
of those seats should have been Barack Obama's
choice, should have been Merrick Garland. But
thanks to Mitch McConnell from the completely
anti-democratic Senate, being able to obstruct
that nomination long enough for Donald Trump to
eventually install Neil Gorsuch. So it makes sense
that with such a prominent decision now in the
forefront, you would have Americans saying,
I don't I'm not confident in this court. I don't
approve of what this court is doing. And some you
know, Coleman Hughes yesterday said it's a feature
of the Supreme Court that it is sort of insulated
from public pressure, public opinion, etc..
That's fine. That would be a feature to me as
well as as I thought about it overnight, I came
to this realization. That's all well and good,
assuming we're confident about the way we got
to these nine people on the court. And I'm not.
I'm not. I mean, again. Lose it to presidents
who lost the popular vote. Got to decide.
Thanks to the votes from Republican senators
from disproportionately lower population states,
giving these Republican senators outsized
influence. I'm going from memory here and don't
hold me to this. But we looked at a statistic
where something like. Oh, I think it was,
Senator. You could have a situation
where you have a majority in the Senate.
With the senators that represent
only 17% of the American population.
Because of that population. Sue I hope that makes
sense. So it makes sense to me that you are seeing
this swing. As many have noted, you don't
usually see such significant swings on major
issues of public opinion, something that it's
not every day people don't think every day about,
do I do I have confidence in the Supreme Court or
don't I? That's not something most people think
about every day. People are busy living their
lives and working, and to see such a drastic swing
in such a short period of time isn't common. And
so on the one hand, it's good in that lots of
people seem to be paying attention to something
that they often wouldn't. On the other hand,
we don't really have much recourse here, and
that's by design, and that would be fine,
assuming we felt good about the process,
I don't. And I'm curious to hear from you.